Speaker 1: Let's take a look at a so-called
lawyer. Apparently trying to defend and
represent her client. I'm going to play some
videos for you of Donald Trump lawyer olina,
Haba olina Haba doesn't know what's going on,
apparently, because she's going back to this old
idea that the FBI might have planted evidence at
Mar a Lago. Now, I know you must be saying, David,
we're like weeks into this thing. We got beyond
that. Trump said, yes, he had the documents,
but he declassified them telepathically,
potentially. Why are they going back to the
evidence might have been planted. It's because
it's just the circle of nonsense. There were no
documents. They were there but planted by the FBI.
There were there because Trump declassified them
and wanted them for his library, slash memoirs,
slash to read. But they weren't actually there
because the FBI planted it. It's just a circle.
It just it's like a moebius strip of absurdity.
Here is Alina. Have a take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Well, do you have evidence that the
FBI might have planted planted something,
anything at Mar a Lago seven weeks ago?
Speaker 4: You know what? We know, and
I'm not going to speak into details.
Speaker 1: Because you don't have any evidence
even that unusual. Do you have evidence? You know
what we know, and I'm not going to speak
about details. The answer is you have no
evidence that anything was planted.
Speaker 4: It would obviously be
confidential to the defense, the case, the
attorneys handling it, which I am not. But
as I have said on the show before,
I think the concern is that we have
recordings of these agents going in and then
they were not permitted to watch the agents.
Speaker 1: We see agents go in. We see
agents come out and we just don't know
what of what they took out was actually
brought in by that. But but do you have
any evidence? But there's no evidence. But we
saw them go in and we saw them come out bare.
Speaker 4: Lago go into his office space, for
instance, or his home, his bedroom or Melania's
closet. And that is incredibly concerning. Another
thing is they came in with equipment, with bags.
So you never know. And fortunately, the car they.
Speaker 1: Brought, bags.
Speaker 4: That we're in politically has led
us to believe that we can't really be sure
that they're following the rule of law at any
point. And that's the most concerning thing,
I think, for all Americans right now.
Speaker 1: And understand the wishy washy
language. We don't know what they did in there.
We don't know whether they're following the rule
of law. Do you? It's the same thing with the
voter fraud stuff. Do you have specific evidence
to suggest a belief ex rather than we've not been
able to rule out? But but do you have any evidence
of x? What leads you to believe that Trump might
have actually won Georgia? Well, listen, we just
don't know who won. There's irregularities and we
don't know who won. And it's always good. Do you
have a reason to believe that Trump specifically
got more votes than Biden in Georgia? We don't
know. What we're calling for is a full investigate
will, but an investigation has been done. It's the
exact same thing. Do you have evidence? We don't
know what went on. The FBI brought equipment
and they weren't on camera during the search
in Trump's office. Okay. Asked what Donald
Trump is doing now, I guess she says Trump's
handling the investigation by playing golf.
Speaker 2: But at some point, Alina,
this has got to take a toll on just
somebody's psyche. All these lawsuits,
all these jurisdictions. How's he doing?
Speaker 4: I hate to burst everybody's bubble,
but, you know, and then when I say everybody,
I mean the DNC, the left wing attackers. But I
can tell you, I was with him a couple days ago.
He is his usual selfie is in great spirits.
He is out there working. He is on the golf
course. He is doing what he would normally do.
Speaker 1: The framing is like he's a victim. Is
he still in good spirits despite this horrible
thing that's being done to him, folks? This is
a guy being investigated as a possible criminal.
Speaker 4: And quite honestly, really optimistic
for the midterm elections and optimistic for
the country's future post Biden regime. Right.
And I think that's what makes a leader.
You can't get down when the country is
failing and you're under siege. You are.
Speaker 1: So anyway, you might be wondering,
why would a lawyer do this? This lawyer, Olina
Haba, who's been increasingly present in media.
Why would why would just a lawyer take this as
a job? You have to understand. She's primarily
like a political actor. And if you look at
her Instagram, you actually see she calls
herself a patriot and a litigator with the
American flags. Her pictures are with Trump,
her going to Mar a Lago and posting propaganda
about Trump, posting pictures with Trump,
posting a picture at one point with I'm not
even going to show it, but like with her kid,
her kids wearing a Trump hat. This is primarily an
individual acting as a political actor, not as a
lawyer. And she actually said, I'm not one of the
people representing Trump in the legal proceedings
here she's representing. Trump on television.
And it's absolutely and completely pathetic